okay so free agency happened this week
as planned although it was somewhat
different than normal especially because
of the physicals constrained by the
covet 19 procedures the draft will
happen april 23 to 25 even if it is
roger goodell sitting by his fireplace
in slippers with a pipe and a newspaper
reading off the names one at a time and
we'll still have the highest ratings
we've ever seen for the draft peter the
schedule usually comes out in april
should that continue or should there be
a different timetable for announcing
when and where the 256 regular season
games will be played
well mike that's a very very interesting
question
because
what has happened for the last five
years i have had access to that room
when they've made up the schedule
the first
i think the first four years i wrote
about it and then last year i did it as
a podcast so i did it as sort of a live
podcast with howard katz and mike north
and the people on the on the scheduling
team inside the nfl
and
it always has seemed to me
okay
you're a week be they do this a week
before the draft
and there is always this incredible
intense
computer spitting out mondo schedules
and and it's all for a rush because they
want to get this schedule out before the
draft and they don't want to get it out
on wednesday of draft week they want to
get it out the week before so people can
breathe and accept that and and sort of
you know
figure out what this schedule means
and then the next week they you know
they have obviously the draft
and i think there are some people in the
league who've always said look we know
that people need to make plans
teams need to start scheduling we get
that
but man it would be nice
for the schedulers
if we knew
what team tua tagovailoa is playing for
in 2020 in 2020 and and some other
people
not only to give this a little bit of
time to breathe in a year when right now
if you're those guys right now and
you're sitting there and you are
less than a month before the release
date you're maybe
23 days
before the release date or 24 days
something like that
you have no idea
who's playing quarterback for the new
england patriots
uh you have no idea what's going to
happen to cam newton
you you have no idea for instance
what's going to happen probably on four
or five they got big decisions to be
made on four or five
marquee teams
you know you're putting the the chiefs
on
six times in in uh in prime time you
know that
but
i do think that there is some
situation right now in some sentiment
inside the league where they might want
to wait
until they have a little bit more
certainty especially with what with
everything else that's going on and mike
there's one other thing
that
a smart person like you would realize
when considering this
one of the things that i kept thinking
about
when tom brady was choosing his team
it was very very it was a big deal in
some circles inside the nfl
honestly i think the nfl would much
rather have had tom brady choose an afc
team
okay because if you think about it
where are all the draws right now
okay the draws right now with the
exception of say the chiefs and
traditional draws kind of like the
steelers okay you know there's not
really a draw in the afc south
you know there's there's you know
obviously the ravens and the steelers
you know are a draw but
if the patriots play andy dalton there's
going to be a lot of people who are
going to look at the patriots out of
curiosity but if they're 1-3 on october
1st they don't want the patriots in
prime time
and and so you look at the afc look at
the afc where are the big attractions so
now you look at the nfc and oh my god
now they got tom brady and all of a
sudden the tampa bay buccaneers are
going to have to be a five-time
primetime team they're going to have to
be they're not going to be playing at
one o'clock on sundays anymore
very much
so you try to look at all these things
and does that mean for instance
that they do a lot more crossover games
this year than they normally do there's
all these things that if i'm just
looking at it mike
i say i will not be surprised if the nfl
says
we're gonna release the the schedule
this year on on may 2nd and not april
18th
well i also think peter there's wisdom
in creating more of an event from the
schedule release instead of a week
before the draft if you bump it into may
middle of may you make it another tent
poll right free agency this week a great
diversion and distraction for people who
needed it the draft will be the same
thing you push the schedule into may for
the reasons you discussed and from a
business standpoint there's a way to
build it up there's a way to milk it
there's a way to maybe bleed it out over
multiple days where they announce the
schedule maybe one team at a time or
something like that to give the rest of
us something we can sink our teeth into
and fully and properly digest and fill
that void on the calendar and it's not
just selfishness by the nfl to try to
own the moment it's the idea that it
gives people something that will keep
them sane at a time when they're going
to be expected to stay inside so you
could make the schedule release i think
a three-night event a tuesday wednesday
and thursday night in the middle of may
just to give people something to look
forward to and something they'll stay
home and watch and they need these are
all look they're they need somebody in
the nfl whose job is to do one thing and
one thing only identify all the ways the
world is going to potentially unfold
over the next six months and come up
with every possible strategy and
possibility for filling those voids and
handling those issues in a way that is
good for the league and that is good for
the people who rely on it
i'll tell you what you're one insane
human being
has anybody i told you that i mean why
a three day schedule release
i'm just say hey
and i'm not even hey i'm not saying it's
wrong i'm not saying it's wrong i'm
saying that's what we've come to because
you understand
that
anything any little any little nugget
about the nfl
is going to be a 40-minute show on espn
i mean right because and it's and it's
something that makes and it makes it
makes people it gives you something to
look forward to and it and it makes
people willing to stay inside and comply
with what they need to do so they really
need to think about it i think you're on
to something there for a variety of
reasons they should bump it into may who
cares if
if ron rivera
doesn't know when he's gonna face the
cowboys is it early is it late how's
that really affect the draft anyway gee
i better go out and get more corners
because i faced
i faced the cowboys week one and forget
about it move it forward and i agree
with you on that complete
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports